Gotham just messaged me and said I
should attempt this and he released a
video a few days ago
of attempting to beat all 15 beginner
bots in less than 30 minutes and
assuming this goes on YouTube I'll link
his video below but he said I should try
this and see if I can beat him I can't
even recall if I've played the beginner
Bots
I've heard of Martin
who's like the worst chess entity on the
planet
but then there's a bunch of other people
too dark chess will be saved for some
time in the future but for now it'll be
beginner Bots and the goal is to win
every game as quickly as possible
ideally I would like to beat Levy
so I guess spoiler Levy managed to do it
in slightly less than 20 minutes
I don't remember his exact time but I'll
check after
I do the speed run
so here we go March in time for your
destruction and part of this is actually
knowing how to start the game
so I'll start with block here and then
I'll be white
so play and then start okay it's
beginning
uh type free move
hey yeah yeah
I'm just trying to checkmates
okay it's all about taking material
okay I'm up
already up a little bit of material up a
queen now
and now I just want to Checkmate as
quickly as possible
I have to bring pieces towards the king
uh
okay dreaming of Queen F2 checkmate
this is progress
no Ah that's not checkmate
don't take my Bishop
wait it's almost mates
ah the King is slippery
Knight F3 checkmates
let's go discover double checkmates next
spot
wait how do I flip the color though
okay there we go
uh E4
okay that was just over a minute
play a scotch we're playing Wayne
who's playing the elephant Gambit
I don't have time to read what they're
saying
okay Knight D5 looks attractive
looks very attractive I could have taken
on F7 but
now I do
let's take
where's my mate
that's a funny line threatening made in
one
go
okay new game
I think I have to do random color
random challenge
okay now now it should alternate
so playing Fabian
Fabian
or faviano without the o
what does A5
yeah the keto winning quickly is uh
essentially just get the pieces out and
create the trackmate threats like F7 is
already like undefendable
um where's my mate
C5 checkmate
let's go got the pawn mate next spot
okay playing Juan
how many Bots have I played
okay let's take a rook
it's a true beginner opening
am I on Pace I think I'm on Pace
I've won three games
so this is number four
part of this is just moving quickly
already dreaming of smothered meat like
not have three at some points
okay going after this Pawn which is
defended enough times maybe the queen
can come in
Queen is intruding
Dole I hung a knight
I don't want this one game to Slow Me
Down
okay we're gonna sock everything and
hope it's made
checkmates okay another double Checkmate
next spot
I think I'm just random colors
uh Stafford Gambit time
I'll try and punish this opening
let's play this
I like how I played D3 really quickly
there
okay me too is not a good move
it probably learned from Magnus and
akaru
and playing the bong cloud
where's my mate
check
gotta bring the knight in
oh it's so close
it's not blunder Queen
check
where's my mate
ah
oh no my knight please take it
there we go another double Checkmate I
can't be stopped
okay
I feel so powerful
okay we're playing Levy's opening the
Vienna Grande
oh
this is like some Theory
the musio this is muzio like
Jack
okay there's about four is coming
check and mate okay next spot
playing null
oh no my pong
well it's not a free thing
I should have taken the Knight
or pushing all the Pawns
uh on G5 I'm making blunders but it's
not punishing me
they are beginner bats oh
okay trying to clamp down
I want to play Queen E4 checkmate
uh can I set up a smothered means
I'm threatening made in three let's go
okay next spot
I've lost track how many beginner Bots
are there there's 15
I hope someone's keeping track
all right they're getting a little bit
stronger
I'll play E5
trying to accelerate development
that's a free Bishop
yeah a lot of these are just hanging
pieces
okay F3 wins the knights it's on passant
take the Knight
wait what just happened oh well I have a
queen I have two queens
but how do I checkmate
remove the defense of the king
let's check
and then mate oops
Chuck
am I losing a queen
oh Chuck
ah how do I how do I destroy it
okay
there we go
next game playing Malika
staff for Gaba time
[Music]
is it gonna go into the Stafford
Stafford Gava time let's go
oh let's crush it with a Saturn it gives
back the pawn right away
and it's not following opening
principles
Queen E7
uh okay Knight G3 winning The Rook
I'm double attack
okay Bishop F4
[Music]
getting closer
time is really ticking here
okay I want to play C5 and open up the
file I missed a fork
but then I found it
chuck chuck
where's my mate
Chuck
I got a rook lift
ah this is so frustrating the king is so
slippery
oh why is that not meat oh that's me
okay
oh it's so confusing
playing janjay
I'll play a Danish Gambit how about
at the 10 minute Mark was G5
okay
I'm sacrificing some quality of my moves
just to try and move quickly
okay I wants to do the moist critical
mates
okay lots of okay that's a free Queen
ah
it takes a lot of focus to find the
quick win
again the king is slippery
there we go okay next spot
11 minute mark
why am I playing the London
all right let's try and win quickly with
the London
because muscle memory took over there
I don't know why I'm playing the London
I have to open the the position 95
well I meant to play C4
my muscle memory is too powerful
[Music]
okay I'll play F4 we'll have a London
stone wall like hybrid opening
okay threatening need in one
it takes on E5 the file opens
I really want to open the file
wow what is this position
oh no my queen
ah this is gonna be a long game
okay
[Music]
don't take my Knights thank you
trying to win the iPhone it's blundering
a lot of things I just have to take the
undefended things
coordinate the knights
I had missed a pork
the pin plus a fork
take this
all right now it's about coordinating
the bishop rook and Knight
and winning Connect Four
Jack
five
okay getting much closer
there we go
okay 13 minutes
no time to waste let's play a scandi
what is this
almost like a hillbilly
because this turned into a Cairo Khan
somehow
attacking the queen
what is this
okay almost meeting
really close
attacking the rook and Chase the queen
away
take the Rook
it's getting weird
so I want to promote the pawn
okay there we go
that's a free Queen
okay next spot playing Zara
I think this is a final beginner bot
850 850 is capable of playing like a
more reasonable game
okay these flight squares are very weak
are going straight for the kill here
ah
a 15 minute Mark has passed
but
crashing through
is that it
I think that's it
wait new game
oh no there's two more
ah I'm white okay there's two more
why am I playing a London again
okay let's play E4
now it's a French
okay the first stop is developing
and the second step is checkmating
actually the second step is probably
sacking at some point
attacking The Rook
uh it feels really close to some other
mates eventually
for H4
it's a hard position to crack though
I'm Gonna Keep My Knights
on poisson
we might trade Queens
Dole I hung a thing
I'm objectively worse here
but I have counter play
wait I have to be careful not to lose
this
I'll lift The Rook
okay I'm mating
that was a close one though
okay next spot final one final boss
Kareem
hey we have a funny Gambit
G4
this is a stun Gambit
threading this is this
actually that wasn't really a threat
Bishop G5
can I win in
okay let's take
I want to win the next 30 seconds
Chuck
getting close
G1 can be pre-moved
oh no
my queen
was a bad pre-move
oh no
wait I'm down a piece
ah
okay Levy scored like 19 minutes or
something
uh this is gonna be close
okay blunder's a piece
thank you very much
I gotta get my knight involved
yeah it plays a good move
that's finding good moves
okay not that move though
okay threatening made in one
not quite neat though
okay making progress it was a free rook
that I missed
oh no my knight
oh no my other Knights
let's go
oh no both my Knights and my time okay
that's the final bar right
yeah that was a final beginner about
just over 19 minutes
Levy got 1922 really I'd be lovey by
by how many seconds
21 seconds
okay
I hope people enjoyed that
um those watching live on Twitch but
also those watching in the future on
YouTube it feels good to destroy so many
beginner Bots
and also destroy Levy's
previous record